so the the course the course evolution
has actually been more a refinement than
a really big any really big evolution
we've always had the four project
structure we have done some juggling of
the amount of time allotted to each
project and what we're asking for the
goals for each project the first year we
ran the course we were kind of asking
for a full game prototype from each of
the iterations and we were asking them
to do everything for every project which
was a little much to ask them although
they did it I mean they did it we've
more we've been refining each of the
projects as it goes to try to the to try
to emphasize a particular thing we're
trying to teach especially in the first
three project so the first project is
prototyping and the second project is
project management and the third project
is now user interface and interactions
feedback especially and then the fourth
project remains tie it all together into
one 1 overall synthesis also I think
that our use of guest lecturers has
gotten better over the years we've been
able to reach out to more people and
we've realized more and more the value
that they bring into the course having
people to come in and talk often
agreeing with what we said but giving a
different perspective and routing it
back in the game industry where the
students the students really like to
hear that this is actually what's going
on in the game industry they're not just
being taught this stuff in a course when
we first started teaching this class we
were primarily looking at the skills
that MIT students had and it didn't have
when they came and joined our lab as
undergraduate research assistants and we
found that that was a certain skill gap
of things that we had to teach every
single new student who came as even
though they may have been very skilled
programmers they didn't understand what
it was like to work in a team and so a
lot of the genesis of this particular
cost comes from just us trying to
increase that pool of students that we
could hire as undergraduate researchers
and of course in the process of teaching
a class about making video games a lot
of the students taking the class were
also interested too
in working professionally in the game
industry and so we expanded the content
on what is going to the skills that
you're going to need outside of MIT but
we've always been very very careful to
make sure that a student who comes out
of that class is in good shape to be
able to get a research internship here
in a lab so this semester on product
three is is is different than last last
year last year the focus was on
aesthetics so think about how art and
sound and visual combined to make it an
aesthetic experience that's not as
important this here for our final
project so we changed it to something a
little that's actually going to help
them with a final project a little
better so in this case its user
interface we're asking to make these
decision-making strategy like games
there's going to be a lot of elements on
the screen that the player is going to
have to understand immediately what they
do and how they interact with each other
so focusing on that user interface and
that user experience is important for us
and in particular feedback systems so
with a meat because our theme is
meaningful decision-making if I'm making
a decision part of it is I should know
what does the decision was that I just
made how it affected the rest of the
world and how it affected my own my own
play so that kind of reinforcing the
kind of feedback loop is going to be
very important for that third project
we've also brought back something that
we temporarily departed from and that's
the idea of having a client a real
client who who has a need for the games
that need to be made in reality if you
go out and work in a game industry
you're not making games for yourself
most of the time then we can game for
someone else so in this case we're going
to be working at the climate center and
the humanitarian response lab here at
MIT to talk about issues of climate
change and more importantly about
preparing for disasters we we feel this
kind of like topical relevance will
might make it make this to start
additionally more interesting for for
for Sutton's to students who who aren't
just enamored with the technical
challenges of making a game but I think
this might also be the first time that
we specifically
had the client give us a a design theme
as opposed to a technology to work with
you so so as a departure but in many
ways is taking what we've learned from
the previous two iterations of this
class where we didn't have a client or
you know all when we have students
working on a design team rather than a
technology and putting it together in
this year